(woman speaking Russian)
- [Reporter] Months after Russia's siege
on the city of Mariupol
which saw some
of the war's worst fighting
Yulia Sazonova's husband
Vladimir and thousands of others
are still unaccounted for.
Now, Russian troops patrolled
the largely empty streets
of this strategic southern
port city that was once home
to almost 450,000 people.
Those that remain are largely cut
off from the outside world.
(Yulia speaking Russian)
The United Nations estimates as many
as 90% of residential
buildings were damaged
or destroyed in the battle for Mariupol.
Now entire housing blocks
are being demolished
and Russia is rapidly
erecting new complexes.
As families scramble to find the dead
and missing before it's too late
raising fears that evidence of war crimes
and any trace of the missing
could be wiped away forever.
This video is pieced
together from hundreds
of social media videos
over the last five months.
Video diaries from two women
searching for loved ones and
from volunteers assisting with
the effort to get a glimpse
of the rush to locate the missing.
Since the siege ended in May, Yulia
and many others have
been using any resources
they can access to find their loved ones
enlisting volunteers,
(Door banging)
scouring telegram channels
and posting missing
notices around the city.
(camera person speaking Russian)
(sad music)
A group of friends who
used to post YouTube videos
of gymnastic tricks
began filming themselves
exploring the city after it fell.
Commenters soon asked them
to search for the missing.
(boy speaking Russian)
(men speaking Russian)
(bombs blasting)
During the siege, many people took shelter
in basements while others fled the city.
With communications down and
their lives thrown into chaos.
thousands of people lost
contact with each other.
(Kateryna speaking Russian)
Kateryna lost touch with
Alexei in early March.
Shortly after the war began, after living
through attacks on the
city for more than a month
she and her family were
eventually evacuated
and settled in Germany.
In June, that same month, she reached
out to a volunteer who identifies himself
as Dmitri in his YouTube videos to look
for Alexei at his home on Kuprina street.
(Dmitri speaking Russian)
(melancholy music)
Kateryna tried following the
leads from Alexei's neighbors.
With little luck, Yulia has filed reports
with Russia's occupying forces
as she works to piece
together what happened
to her husband since he
disappeared in March.
During a brief walk home
(Yulia speaking Russian)
With leads on the ground
coming up short, Yulia
and Kateryna both wondered
if their loved ones might be
in prison somewhere, Kateryna turned
to the internet for help.
(Kateryna speaking Russian)
Kuprina Street, where Alexei was living
is a particularly stark example
of the rapid pace of Russia's
rebuilding of the city.
In recent months, the boys searched
for people at 69 Kuprina Street in August.
(boys speaking Russian)
Since August, we found at
least six buildings have
been demolished on one side of the street.
Recent satellite imagery
shows one of those buildings
was 69 Kuprina Street.
The new Russian buildings
are visible on the other side
of the street.
(people chattering)
The arrival of winter and
Mariupol brings the contrast
and conditions of the city into focus.
Shining new apartment
complexes continue to appear
as the boys encounter
residents living a drastically
different reality.
(boys speaking Russian)
(man speaking Russian)
(melancholy music)
While those still searching,
desperately hope their
loved ones are alive.
Videos of growing burial
sites in Mariupol have
been circulating for months.
They show fresh graves marked
with numbers in the thousands.
Authorities in Mariupol
have said that DNA samples
of the dead were taken so that
missing people can be traced
in the future.
Experts in finding missing
people in conflict say it
will take years to locate
those who are still unaccounted
for, and it's unlikely
everyone will be found.
The Russian embassy in
Washington DC did not respond
to requests for comment
regarding the whereabouts
of missing persons in Mariupol
and concerns that human
remains are being discarded.
(Kateryna speaking Russian)
(bulldozer banging)
(Yulia speaking Russian)
(melancholy music)